but there seems to be a warmth between
these two gentlemen there's a bigger
strategic question about how important
geopolitically the UK is to the US now
we are not members of the EU anymore
here he comes President Biden
indeed Beth and extraordinary actually
the scale of Security operation even in
Downing Street where everyone has to be
so well cleared to even be there but
here comes the president a warm smile on
his face both arms out as he presumably
has just seen prime minister sunac and a
little skip in his step and a very broad
smile Beth just uh took us through there
well if you can hear anything but
certainly a very warm greeting between
the two men yeah very very warm
you can hear all the Press now now
shouting
um there's a huge Bank of camera and and
in they go in they go and then you can
see
um some of the security detail and then
the Press packs I don't know if you can
see this all this is everyone running in
because they will now be covering the
top of the bilateral so everyone running
running through and then you can see the
delegation as you said the Ambassador
there and there's the U.S delegation now
all coming in a big delegation isn't it